hi I have a gentleman he is um six feet
is about 180
he has throat cancer he's on chemo right
now stage three and we've put together
something for him however I questioned
the BTT okay and now you're talking
about the tablets no not the tablets the
drink okay yeah well there's a basic
ninety which includes the 90 essential
nutrients right 16 minerals 16 botanist
Pro Minister 3 fatty acids you're going
to need the at the very least the basic
healthy start pack but if somebody has a
history of stage 3 cancer stage 2 cancer
even stage one cancer they got to have
the basic raw materials for the cells
and the immune system to begin to crank
up and begin to defend the patient and
so somebody has cancer
I'd go beyond the healthy start tech I
go with the healthy brain and heart
attack
what is this guy weigh 180 ok 180 I'd
have him take how many of those healthy
start packs would you have them take
Charmaine well at least two yeah at
least 2 and if you were going to throw
in a couple more items to support
communities and what would you do to add
to the to healthy brain and heart
attacks
I would thrown the Z radical and the BTT
2.0 tablets tablets right now the BTT 2
2.0 tablets four of those a day will
give you 160,000 or AG points oxygen
rankled fancy which is a measurement of
how many free radicals are neutralized
by the antioxidants in a supplement and
you want to get over a hundred thousand
so you get one bottle as charge says of
the BTT 2.0 tablets she can take or he
excuse me can take two of those at
breakfast into his dinner time that
would give them 160,000 work points I
take five hundred thousand word points a
day just for prevention so you got stage
3 I'd go with the BTT 2.0 4 twice a day
that would give him 320,000 work points
and the Z radical which are said I'd
have them take at least 2 ounces a day
maybe in 3 ounces a day has the coin in
it legendary
in the Pacific the Japanese attribute
their lower rate of cancer than the
United States and Europe to difficult
and they attribute their greater
survival rate in America and Europe to
cancer to the few Crichton and of course
we have that in the Z radical Z like
zebra - in the word radical so liquid
comes in quartz at the very least he
should have two ounces of a today
announcer breakfast sounds and enter
again to support the immune system and
money is not an object I didn't take
three of those ounces a day and anything
else you would throw into the stage
three is pretty serious life-threatening
sharp what else I would throw in the
oceans gold and why would you like the
oceans no that's for thyroid isn't it no
well for it's got the sea cucumber in it
- ah very good very good yeah sea
cucumbers legendary for supporting the
immune system for people who have cancer
and the beauty about supporting the
immune system is what you're going to do
is not going to negatively affect the
healthy cells chemotherapy does kill
cancer cells but guess what it also
kills normal cells and that's why 97% of
the people who take him as therapy fail
chemotherapy fails 97% of the time as it
kills the healthy cells as well as the
cancer cells so I hope that helps you
out and you know that would give this
individual a good boost by supporting
the immune system and I like chars ideas
through the Healthy Start pact and you
have something life-threatening go for
the bigger hammer and take the healthy
brain and hard pack okay